whether we restore them we have butcher
your name - charlie
coach also talking about dress trouble
thank you I already ate come here thank
you for your invitation
sorry it's a joint work with havoc on
our carpet okay so so we say that we
will consider a coned a convex cone
which is open so no reserve see for open
legs and I consider a smooth function on
this cone that takes on the positive
values
okay and I say that app it is completely
monotone
F is completely monotone and I will
abbreviate it to CM if if I take any
vectors my cone and I take the
directional derivatives again respect to
this vectors of my function happen
this one has to be always non-negative
function up to the side where K is a m--
and you have seen a definition which
looks similar in the talk of sincere but
it's not I don't know like what is the
relation between well concave functions
and from Bonta functions even have the
definitions look very similar so for
example you can think of positive person
okay and then this condition is
equivalent to taking all kinds of
partial derivatives this has to be
non-negative on positive person
and some examples of functions of this
kind are you can take for example half
of X to be e to the power minus X then
the common here is positive lying okay
and you can easily check that when you
take any kind any case derivative of
this function and it will be positive
whenever X is positive and another
example is okay
another example is okay you take
reciprocal of your variable this will
this will also be a function on positive
whoreson positive line and you can also
check that and taking derivative the
change the sign of the derivative just
alternate okay and we will be interested
in functions that are a very specific
type they will be inverse powers of
hyperbolic polynomials okay
and in general for any kind of functions
like doesn't matter whether F comes from
a hyperbolic polynomial or not there is
a beautiful characterization of
completely monotone functions that is
due to various time
close door either and check it they
didn't write paper to get this highway
so they're Stein proofed it in one
variable and then I think Jacob gave
like for generalization to any cones in
any dimension okay then theorem says
that F defined on C is completely
monotone you cannot live there exist a
moral measure as a dual of this cone so
by C star I will you know the clothes do
okay
so forth if somebody doesn't know so
this have consists of our vectors and it
also you also have not your lateral
identify around visits you such that our
product of Y is X is always non negative
for any X in my cone C there exists a
measure on this dual cone
such that f of X can be represented as e
to the power minus y X D mu of Y
so I measure on sISTAR I mean measure
that is supported on system okay and
this theorem is a very powerful because
this condition tells you that infinitely
many conditions hold five so in
particular for example when F is an is
the inverse power of a polynomial unique
you will get infinitely many
non-negative polynomials on some C or
for example on positive Orson so it's
like in fees you cannot check it right
and this condition guarantees that if
you are able to find a measure such that
this representation halts then this
infinite series of inequalities hold
forever it's easy to check actually that
this is a sufficient condition because
when you apply any kind of derivative
plus monomial of in Y pops out and you
integrate a positive monomial against
positive measure and they'll get again
something positive and this theorem was
law for example if if you take one of
these two examples for example if f of X
is e to the power minus X then this
measure so it's it's so the measure has
to be supported on the deal of this
positive line which is itself no
negative line right and the measure here
is just direct measures that is
supported in in one at point one so it's
shifted direct measure so just when you
plug in this measure here you'll get
exactly it was a power minus X and for
another function f of X reciprocal of X
this natural moon is just the back
measure on positive Orson
it's actually easy to check because X to
the power minus 1 is e to the power
minus y times X dy and you integrate
from 0 to infinity and you will have to
change your variables this is actually
an identity so you can easily verify
this okay now for month from now on P
will be a hyperbolic polynomial which
will be always from a genius okay and I
will denote by C C or sometimes angle
drop P it's hyperbole silicon so
sometimes of course I need to specify so
for Las Colinas of course there's only
one hypervelocity comet and there are
two I need to specify which cone from
the hyperbolic but I will always assume
that P is positive on C because because
of this definition so I want to take on
the positive functions okay and then I'm
interested in the following question
when and or evil P to the power minus
alpha which is a perfectly defined
function that takes positive values on
my cone C is completely monotone and in
fact this question was studied I feel
like this activity has something to do
with another word semester that took
place here yes bear right like four or
five years ago and parent Matthias
Caroline and dr. spevak they they
studied this and they wrote a paper and
I will talk about it in the next five
minutes okay so first of all if if P is
not necessarily hyperbolic it's just a
homogeneous polynomial with real
coefficients
that is completely such that such that
is a homogeneous polynomial such that P
to the power of minus alpha is
completely monotone then you must be
hyperbolic
is expect to see okay and this
essentially follows from this integral
representation because if this
interpretation calls for inverse power
of P then in fact you can it's actually
a theorem but it's not easy it's not
difficult to prove that the function can
be extended analytically to the tube
domain namely to the domain this will be
the only proof I'm going to present in
my talk if the Senators power is
completely monotone then you can there
exist a holomorphic function extension
of this function of this of this
function on C plus I R M so you consider
for example on C is positive person this
is exactly the domain that appeared in
the talk of Josephine the other can and
that restricts to F okay and this is
actually can check that it's just
they're just equivalent the condition
that Josephine gave you for stability is
always the same as the condition for the
non vanishing for P on this domain right
and this is equivalent for homogeneous
polynomials to be in hyperbolic because
it's
okay and sorry okay so so if if there
exists an alpha which and you can check
that alpha must be necessarily positive
or zero okay if there exists non
negative pulses at lab this is known egg
is completely mount from them you're a
hyperbola okay and okay and how how can
you check like that such represent that
this calls for some inverse power of
your hyperbolic polynomial you need to
kind of find the way the way back from
your function to possibly do what
actually exists in this measure right
but you don't have priori that this
measure exists because otherwise you
would be laughs Danny there is an
inverse operation that out of function
transfer something that is not in
general measure and then we can check
whether this is positive for now and
this is this as an inverse
transformation that is called inverse
Laplace transform so in fact it is a
theorem due to gardening that for any in
fact complete complete means that C is
pointed and so if you have a paucity
count and pointed
then you can go back you can reverse
this procedure and cook up a function
the following function is well defined
that I will denote by Q alpha it will be
function on deposit on that zero of my
code and it looks like as follows
and check it
so you integrate this function which is
actually a complex valued function over
RN or X is my variable and E is any
point in the hyperbola city cone okay
and in fact you can check that this
function the integral the whole integral
takes on the real values as a function
of Y okay and this Q alpha is a
perfectly defined is a continuous
actually function with support so you
don't actually a priori require that Q
is only defined on C star but it will be
automatically satisfied we support in C
star such that
and moreover you can defy you can go
back to P it's actually in the same way
as you did it for completely monotone
function so you integrate Q alpha of Y
dy which is absolutely continuous
function respectively back measure on my
do cone but the problem is this
representation defines of course my
polynomial had multiple around P but
nobody say that this Q alpha is positive
okay
and so I picks in their product of my I
identify if it's brackets oh yes yes yes
sorry yes
sorry by this I mean that professor okay
and okay so the four of people I
mentioned when we burnt not Caroline and
everything they conjectured like four or
five years ago
there exists an alpha that is
sufficiently big so this condition is
actually to ensure that this is a
well-defined function because in general
it might this integral that defines my
cure I might not be able define function
okay the conjecture that there exists
alpha such that Q alpha is always
non-negative and C star okay and it's
still open actually so suppose that one
consequence of this conjecture if it's
true is that every hyperbolic polynomial
admits a negative power that is
completely monotone okay
yes if if Q alpha is non negative then
this representation this theorem tells
you that F is completely monotone on the
cone of hydrophobicity okay and in fact
so that's why I say that completely
monotone functions can be used if if
they come from hyperbolic polynomials
they can be used to construct infinite
sequence of non-negative polynomials on
your cone but in general this conjecture
is open and that mean mention what is
known about that
okay well this conjecture born in this
building yes okay so know in cases of
course the first case you can think
about is a determinant of polynomial
okay and in this case it's actual
settled but it's not actually even more
so if P is some power of P
we admit positive determinant of
representation then there exists alpha
is sufficiently large such that P to the
power minus alpha is completely monotone
okay
or in the same equivalently Q alpha of Y
is non-negative on my copy to sister so
actually this sort of like I have a lot
switched from several times from this
condition and equivalent condition of
being complete monotonicity from this of
this exponent so if such Q if this is
not negative then P to the power of
minus alpha due to this representation
will be completely moment of by this
burnished I'm sure cap theorem and vice
versa if for some sufficiently big alpha
this is completely monotone then Q alpha
defined by that formula will be a non
negative because I forgot mentioned that
this
so due to uniqueness in this statement
so actually I didn't write unique there
exists a unique Borel measure which is
very important so this transformation is
injective like from the space of
measures that support that are supported
on C star into smooth functions this is
a transformation which narrows into
smooth functions
this is injective okay and moreover the
image of positive measures is exactly
completely monotone function C now this
is a complete description just a
tautology okay and this this case is of
course like you can it covers a lot of
hyperbolic polynomials okay and another
key another class of hyperbole
polynomials is before I write let me ask
the audience I think the answer should
be known whether elementary symmetric
polynomial I've made determinant of
symmetric representation up to take in
high enough power
if a power of a mentally medical almost
is known to be determinantal or not I
know that that the the the khalsa
spectra hero but I don't know if they
have made actual determination what what
is out there
yes yes if the power submit to determine
of hesitation
then you wouldn't give beginning this
tour no no no it's not it's not the
purpose of this talk is not to waste
this case I don't know I asked Mario
come here and he said he doesn't know
exactly that's why I said that before I
write something I want the bishop yes it
was if it was explicit I would be able
to you want to say that Q is called the
risk oh oh sorry
definition which is I actually cafes
called it's called please colonel
of me okay so and so the answer is not
not right okay
so then the second class is a class
elementary of elementary symmetric
polynomials okay and in this case it's
known that the conjecture holds and you
need to take alpha big enough to exhibit
such matter Q alpha saturates kernel and
yeah and this will appear in my first
common reference okay and that's more or
less what this node so far in this case
how explicitly skewered father okay I
will talk about it right now
so Q alpha in the first case it's
actually very interesting so it's it has
appeared already in statistics paper and
I think people that know a little bit of
probability have encountered but where
it is this java in an explicit way so so
in the first case we can say okay first
let me take determinant of a where I do
not I just considered a to be any K by
in any matrix and positive definite code
and that the size will be M okay this is
my P of a there was a result of Scott
and Socko which is very beautiful and
it's a complete characterization of
exponents
which this function is completely
monotone
if and only if alpha is one of the
following it's either half integer our K
is from 0 to n minus 1 or alpha is
greater than n minus 1 over 2 okay so
it's a complete list of exponents for
which this function is completely
monotone and more where we can write
down the risk kernel okay and for
example in the first case let's call
this case a in this case B in the first
case hey there is kernel is given by the
following integral representation
it's are announced Oh
determinant of a to the power minus K or
two equals x for integral over the space
so let me first write you and explain
oops sorry it's a Gaussian either
it's a Gaussian in exactly D X where the
XS so X will be nitrix
K by n matrix filled by vectors X X 1
etc X K so it will be run K matrix okay
because K is in this range so it's
between 0 and minus 1 and the X is just
has actually scaled lebesgue measure the
XJ our relative party
they take entrance of this madness of
there are key times many entries and you
just kill each other by square root of
pi and this is my lebesgue measure of DX
okay
and you integrate over the space and in
fact it does not look the same as this
formula because here you see that it's
another so x intercept energy but
linearly here but here we integrate over
in other words the cone of mattresses
but we kind of push forward our measure
which back we will kind of pull back our
measure to the set of run K matrices
that are defined by X so I consider this
transformation this map from X to x
times X transpose and I end up in
positive semi-definite come off rod of
size k of size M which is the Otto
definite code okay and then then this
defines you explicitly as a measure we
very quiet because then it just the
measure will be pushed forward of the
lebesgue measure the X through this map
okay and in the second case when
exponent is large enough yes this is
called Wishart distribution exactly
thank you
that's why I said that people know that
no probability or statistics we should
recognize at the music
and in fact note that this measure is
not absolutely continuous this hue alpha
in this sense does not exist because
this measure what is the image of this
map it's the set of mattresses of rank
at most k right so it's it leaves on the
boundary of the of the PSD code okay so
as a function this K alpha does not
exist but it said in dieter measure
which is positive [ __ ] and this
defines my norisse measure or which is
not function but still it's dinner okay
and in the second case when alpha is at
least n minus 1 over 2 or greater sorry
actually strictly greater my function
means the following representation it's
or after some constant that I don't
write later integral over positive
semi-definite comb
so my scalar product here is a trace
color product or through Venus color
product if you want and the measure is
given by this VD here is a product of D
bij
so all entries on the diagonal and above
okay and the constant M is some ugly
constant that is the M to the power 4
times product of gamma functions
okay and this function is now about
defiant faction it's continuous function
you can make sure it's actually smooth
function on the positive side of the
earth on the boundary of the positive
Center in the interior of the positive
semi-definite code and in particular so
there is an so what can be said about
completely Mountain functions in general
so what operation preserve computer on
tonicity of course you can multiply to
completely Mountain functions and you
will get completely Mountain function
and you can also restrict to a subspace
that across that intersects your console
to if you restrict it to a subspace sub
: okay then the table also completely
Mountain in particular and that's by any
power so if B admits a determinant or
representation up to taken enough power
and of course and after is to up to
taking this power and restricting it to
subspace that is that that is given the
determinate representation you will get
a complete monotonicity okay and one
interesting case which I plan to this
discuss now is the product of linear
form so and so namely one B is just a
product of M many linear forms
particular example
okay particular case of function of this
type as a when P of X is just product of
the uniforms I take em many vectors LM a
pan and I take products of we have
phones defined by this vectors and of
course in fact in this case it's not
only completely monotone for exponents
in this cell but it's actually
completely monotone the inverse power of
this alpha sin inverse powers of it it's
completely mountain for any positive
half because so and you could already
observe it from the example of a
completely monotone function I gave you
on the first board so if you take f of X
to be X to the power minus 1 this is
completely monotone right but in here I
can take any alpha and it will be still
completely more a ton for any positive
alpha right in particular sites easy to
get to complete menthe initiative of one
link for one linear form because it's
essentially taken one variable because
and then when you take product of this
you will also get a completely moment on
functions that's why P to the power
minus alpha in this case is completely
monotone or any other positive okay and
we want to write down the explicit
representation of its inverse power so
we want to get a formula for the risk on
all of this function and the theorem is
that's all so we supposed to like let me
fix so my my ex lives in our end so it's
an very dimensional vector and let me
fix and last linear forms to be
coordinates so I take L M minus N and
minus
and pass one plus high to be IC unit
vector from 1 to n ok so like in
particular my form is divisible by each
coordinate okay my product of linear
forms contains X 1 etc Excel and so the
first M minus M forms any ok then e to
the power minus alpha huh oh thanks I've
made the following representation it's
an integral on the my pot and the consi
star which is in this case but a
polyhedral cone because P is defined by
linear form so it's we hit lock on look
Mike Applebee second is polyhedra and I
risk L now is going by the function that
is called Gelfand almota hyper geometric
function and I will try to explain what
it is now so it will be function that
depends in very complicated way or
meters
but this is for project lovely yes this
is for product of week so this is for
product yes exactly I'm considering only
product of waveforms and this function
is called del Ponte Motta hyper
geometric function is a classical kind
of classical object
[Music]
and okay so let me start with any matrix
of size K times M for what minutes you
this is kind of a very special case
Alexei of course right yes yes so okay
it's interesting because it has lots of
connections to combinatorics because
this function they play a lot a very
important role in combinatorics and if
time permitting I will maybe I have just
ten minutes right I don't know no okay
okay okay
I don't so let me take K by M matrix of
maximum rank such that a is of this kind
it has first minor which is identity
minor and some some entries here okay
and
and let me take any many complex numbers
such that they sum up to n minus K okay
and then the hypergeometric function
that depends on beta on this vector of
parameters and my matrix a is defined as
follows it's integral of products of
linear forms
- KN + 1
I think so my matrix a has came in
erodes right so this K rows they define
K many uniforms I take the linear forms
that are defined by these rows and I
take the positive part of it and take
them as a power BJ minus one and I
integrate against some differential form
over the unit sphere in my space R K so
this s is a unit sphere in my space R K
in fact it doesn't matter what serve
surface I take it should be just
encircling the origin and intersect each
row once so for example a sphere and
Omega of X is a differential form that
is just
it's the final form of order K minus one
so this is a hypersurface of dimension
minus M minus 1 K minus 1 and so I I can
integrate K minus 1 form over a
hypersurface in RK and I get an answer
and some number which is a which is a
function of a and B so this is called
have your phantom water hypergeometric
function and the function that I wrote
here is just let me call this site Allah
so obsessively of alpha-a ly
it was by definition sigh of betta and a
a L of Y where beta is a following
vector of exponents so it takes as the
first place it takes and - us and alpha
ok and and then it has it is filled with
alphas and alpha a alpha of Y is a
matrix AB has first miner to be fixed
and here it has minus y minus L 1 minus
L and sorry actually here I don't have -
so it's very special
so in fact you make sure that it's
matrix of size actually its matrix of
this kind okay doesn't matter what size
it has and yes and and this is a formula
for the risk kernel that is associated
to the product of we napalms
let me just briefly mention why it is
interesting
so for example you can for some special
values of this function of this risk
you'll know you can get some function
that appearing in combinatorics for
example let me take alpha to be 1 so I
am interested in complete monotonicity
of function reciprocal of products of
linear forms okay in this case so I know
that it's completely monotone and in
this case my risk are low so when how
phase one has a following interpretation
I need to integrate I consider consider
a linear map from RM to RM that sense
ice unit vector here into Li one of my
vectors that I picked here okay
so it's a linear for me to put into the
projection from higher dimensional space
to RN and I need to integrate over the
fibers of this linear map intersect it
with a positive force in RM in fact if
you assume that your hyper velocity cone
defined by this linear forms is pointed
these fibers will become packed
polyhedra so in general it's Apple Hill
it's uncomfortable here but under the
condition that hypothetical is appointed
the polyhedron correspondent this will
be a compact polyhedron and you
integrate essentially integrate the
valley you take the volume of your
polyhedron with respect to the back
measure 1 so let me take very ballsy
here and attack the Z and I need to
normalize by the grunion of this linear
transformation so I need to divide by
determinant of GJ transpose okay so it's
you just integrate you compute volume
that varies as a function of Y so you
have so your hyperbola city counci is
just for example and you draw a
two-dimensional picture so this is your
C ok then you have C duo just
your hyperbole City Council which is
also polyhedral and I pick now point
here in what I pick why here okay and
now how what is the value of my risk are
no at this point I just need to compute
the volume with respect to the back
measure up to this normalization which
is constant for all points so it doesn't
depend on the bike and the points I
think I just need to compute the volume
of this polyhedron and this people like
that no combinatorics maybe they have
map in encounter it a discrete analog of
this fashion some people call it the
volume function and in fact it is a
piecewise polynomial function so it's
not just continuous as we expect from
from general theory but it's actually
piecewise polynomial and piecewise
polynomial ax T breaks exactly sorry yes
it's like yes it's like this plan
exactly
but piecewise polling what what is
initially it has so it piecewise
polynomial T brings when Y becomes
dependent with some hyperplanes defined
by my linear forms okay when we cross so
that you can imagine what is a
combinatorial chamber decomposition of
my sister defined bilinear forms okay so
in the in the two-dimensional case for
example if I have three linear forms
then my sister is just spent a positive
span of these vectors and this reactors
look like this so when my Y is here in
but where is in this region every sin is
good to every sin is polynomial also
here every sin is pole down but when I
cross the boundary the problem LT breaks
down it remains continuous but the
function changes and yes and this might
I don't know so we've tried to find more
nice interpretations of this function
and yeah I don't have time to talk about
so what is known for an anti symmetric
polynomial but let me just say that for
the mentally symmetric polynomial as
as I mentioned this conjecture that was
on this blackboard it was settled and
moreover there is another conjecture
that is due to salt Scotland SoCo that
says a following so this is a conjecture
as well but by now it's half of the
conduction half of it this is proved so
elementary symmetric polynomial that I
do not by a man and I take out of power
of it it is completely monotone on
positive for salt
if and only if alpha is either zero or
greater than M minus n minus M over two
and in fact this direction is settled
and it will also also appear in the
first common paper and the other
direction is is open but we know that
for some alpha so we know the
sufficiently big alpha ensures complete
monotonicity of this fashion but the
conjecture is that it works for any I
will find this wrench okay thank you I
don't know much about that but yes it's
true maybe something this form except
you don't have identity you just stuff
the traces potential trace right yes
determinant of a to power minus 1 these
are your BA here for yourself without
this piece yeah okay define us transform
exactly this is a yes I didn't say that
I didn't want to throw in too much room
too much too many terms but this
transformation that defines this inverse
power is called Laplace transform so the
information of this shows the definition
Universal by your shoulders actually I'm
not prepared to talk about that so but I
expect the very solid connection okay
you think there's only hope of extending
this conjecture to like SOS hyperbolic
polynomials
I think the elementary symmetric one is
the conjecture of Scotland soccer this
sort of integral being not negative on
the well but this conjecture Falls for
all so conjectural e this result for all
hyperbolic polynomials
okay exactly and in actually it's also
necessary like burnt ass-kissing like
whether it softly calls for more concave
follow reticent oil but this talent so
like the class is only for is inside
hyperbolic or also a [ __ ] holes I guess
I mention already in the beginning that
if this representation exists with
positive measures and your polynomial
must be hyperbolic it would be
interesting to try persons like if one
assumed some sort of representation
maybe not like determinant but like let
me mention if it's if it will be
interesting to convert Oryx to condemn
tourists that some natural stable pool
mammals that come from graph theory like
for example standing trees standing tree
pollen Ono's for serious terrible graphs
they actually were so for this
polynomials it's also holds that some
inverse power of it is completely
monotone and some some of is these
exponents were listed in the same paper
where this contraction was stated so if
you're interested you can look it up so
like for some combinatorial in defying
say the polynomials you can say
something using like
but that only thing sorry determinantal
are they all did tumor on top yes okay
okay then then okay then okay but
elementary symmetric polynomials they
not all not all of them correspond to
this spanning tree polynomials okay yes
and this question which I asked in the
beginning is seems to be very
interesting like whether there exists
this mental presentation of some power
of electricity the first due to petals
is out it's not interested me if you
know if you want to say something about
the coal but like if you don't want to
be able to break them might be
interesting yeah there are no
conjectures but in fact my personal
belief would be that if there exists one
alpha then there exists such alpha such
that all alpha beyond work but I don't
know but this is not in all my own cases
it's it holds so actually between these
things and somehow partition functions
doing so they said this like the
motivation I think one of the motivation
was to construct so called hyperbolic
exponential families and then they big
they correspond to partition function
probability distribution so this is like
you mentioned this is a Wishart
distribution and this like the product
of linear forms might be it's you can
say something about your probability
distribution in your family in your
polyhedral family let's say using some
properties of hyperbolic problems so for
example these functions they admit nice
description in terms of differential
operator so you you can go to the dual
site and ask which differential
operators killed this function and there
is a rich theory developed you have
supper example people study this
approach unit this idea in the rink of
differential
and Gandhi
so it's trivial for your profile it's
trivial for the product x1 times x2
times exact exactly its directional
derivative do you get the elementary
cement exactly well no no no now you
could get directional derivatives of
products of coordinates you get the
elementary symmetric ball but you need
to be careful because you cannot
exchange the derivative I was saying I
was thinking about that and there is not
such a theorem
there's no there could be yeah but it's
not obvious it's not obvious I mean yeah
exactly
yes it could be one way exactly that was
one of our sorts but you are not able to
say something
there's no other questions or comments
or to thank the speaker again
[Applause]